[Music]
but if you start so she it
quantum mechanics is the one of the
greatest is combs pointed to the president
they know mar bottle series
there polish anything in context
built that had him so the molecule
phrases and tiers up a tune world
this  has been quantum week and i hope the
string thing about spider the fact i
so is so successful in describing the one
that i know it never left as en describe
and is seen that looks like reality
any one to used to working with this
complex  received so sweet that crisis
connects so can and yes
maybe think of if I have some music
gone minus the consensus was the type in the
private century mind that is input if
I say right now that leads and the look at
the right otherwise
zoe  who dat who put them on surfs
in an experiment so hot warm and there's
a the time reality is free
port and injured
siri dat songs more likely to be to
another ferry
this choice is so descried freezings en
aan de acryl
s yes  but  real thing eggs nose or
and real go strike object then here is
a machine
smart-shower cup became so he lives now
is a syrian to 2d active scribe
reality or not
and has wet i know you can make that is
the german scribe things
there pen the acrylic as the first even titles
itself it is also nice if antisocial is
doing such a way that knowledge 3 the
damage the media that goes hopeless with weekend
honeycombs in the we that copy and
the we the thing that the thesis most
license
layers  topcoat stageplan is now like roof
what stage pen set you never seen what i
know the dhd
so same thing mark particles now needed
the third many of them to the floor horse
and do they all this is realistic and
maria that city when he chose hiero real
what  having blonde i saved me sleeveless
so go there that surgery and this would be
difficulty to day that medal she came the
kgb
dooty women's studies from a noble
more serious do more sometimes things of
asia minor is to hanging so beautiful
and shou  ld be correct it
came into the language went professional
is chubby connectis this is so
intimidation and something dit now find
network designen sphere is htc where the
house to be wrong that is just
scribble to make a sink with out salatasi
crash and there is  the moon the economy that
looks and alder is of course the morning star
still air wasn't here about and
this is the way i'll be active if we the
villages becomes elementary particles
or cupboards place where half was ie
so flower garden particles that you create  this
be more real physical particles and it
would be a the mood is to the model district
who donor and zakkie we already
sing particon school somewhere men with uno
keep throwing have rich
na came gary put solid scissors we
can never go beyond that were as english
have to go beyond and said this is
realistic scenario of what could be
happening and how you could be damage
reality
with which the festival like this before in
the closer lanschot lawrence me dat he
wa  s in the simylar the third pretty dry
stage from so us so as but according to
look then make rockstar the
go again chair and his site is there on
that all true is it a simple
skirt
with whom azurill crash and sandy give
cake with  the
the elephant or was already roped it much
more precisely than usual in want to finish already
no much the discussion that i
have to its
[Music]
there was derek automat okay sorts of
captions
after people as elephant crash and sodick
cuban the kind of while  they the
specials action discussions action in the
morning lessons atmosphere is a small group
of people and through it sometimes such a good
calchas'
that we follow the pattern of mode b later and
interviews
subscribe to day to the institute as
medium ah tv